[Música]
el juez instructor del proceso contra
Jair bolsonaro a su culpable al ex
presidente brasileño de abuso de poder
en los comicios de 2022 y votó a favor
de inhabilitarlo para ejercer cargos
públicos durante 8 años todavía se
espera la votación de otros seis jueces
Venezuela rechazó que la cpi reanude la
investigación contra el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro en un comunicado la
presidencia afirmó que los opositores
alegan crímenes de lesa humanidad que
nunca existieron en las protestas de
2017 y dice que la justicia Penal
Internacional está siendo
instrumentalizada
y la Organización de Estados Americanos
en la misión de observación electoral de
la Unión Europea denunciaron
irregularidades en las elecciones
generales de Guatemala la oea pidió que
para la segunda vuelta se disminuya la
atención y los observadores europeos
reiteraron que las votaciones estuvieron
marcadas por la exclusión de candidatos
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de France 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano Gracias por
acompañarnos comenzamos en Brasil el
juez instructor del proceso contra Jair
bolsonaro a su culpable al ex presidente
brasileño de abuso de poder en los
comicios de 2022 y votó a favor de
inhabilitarlo durante ocho años en la
segunda audiencia del juicio celebrada
Este martes en el tribunal superior
electoral la acusación de abuso de poder
y desinformación se vincula a la
utilización de los canales de
comunicación del gobierno para promover
su campaña y para difundir dudas
infundadas sobre el sistema de votación
electrónica en los comicios de octubre
de 2022 todavía se espera la votación de
otros seis jueces nuestra corresponsal
valeriasaconé nos explicaba que se
espera que resulte de este juicio y si
es factible o no que inhabiliten a
bolsonaro
es más que factible la gran pregunta es
cuando Fuentes jurídicas dicen que el
resultado podría ser de 6 a 1 o a los
sumos de 5 a 2 O sea que ya estaría
decidido sin embargo hay una gran
cuestión si el juez afina bolsonaro Raúl
Araujo pide una vista preliminar lo que
podría suspender el juicio de un periodo
de 30 a 60 días en un primer momento se
pensaba que sería otro juez que haría
eso el juez que bolsonaro ha nombrado
para la Corte Suprema sin embargo Raúl
araullo que es un juez muy conservador
tiene que leer ante su voto y podría
hacerlo ha habido muchas presiones por
parte del expresidente Jeff bolsonaro
para que pida esa vida Esa vista
preliminar y lo que es importante que
aunque se suspenda durante 30 o 60 días
el resultado no cambiaría el propio
bolsonaro parece cada vez más conformado
y más
resignado con esa perspectiva de hecho
hoy ha salido una entrevista en la
prensa nacional en que daba
prácticamente por segura su
inhabilitación y la Corte Penal
Internacional retomará su investigación
contra el gobierno de Nicolás maduro por
presuntos crímenes de lesa humanidad
cometidos en Venezuela durante las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales de
2017 la presidencia rechazó la medida y
afirmó que los opositores alegan
crímenes de lesa humanidad que nunca
existieron y dice además que la justicia
Penal Internacional está siendo
instrumentalizada
dialogamos con Marino Alvarado abogado y
coordinador de la Organización de
Derechos Humanos provea acerca de
quechos concretos fueron reportados y
denunciados durante las protestas de
2017 esto nos decía solamente
los asesinatos que ocurrieron en
protesta la detenciones arbitrarias las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales sino que en
el mes de marzo hubo una consulta que
hicieron los jueces de la Corte Penal
Internacional
setenta y cinco opiniones fueron
remitidas a la Corte Penal Internacional
por distintas víctimas entre ellas
comité de víctimas de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales para que se tengan una
idea de quienes nos escuchan solamente
en el 2020 hubo tres mil treinta y
cuatro presuntas ejecuciones cometidas
por funcionarios policiales y militares
en Venezuela
la suma de los últimos años da
aproximadamente siete mil ejecuciones
realizadas pero también muertes por
tortura en el año
constatada dos muertes por cultura entre
ellas funcionarios policiales que
torturaron a otros funcionarios policial
en la sede de la dirección general de
contrainteligencia militar es decir no
solamente han sucedido los crímenes a su
humanidad en Venezuela sino que
continúan cometiéndose crímenes en el
país y la organización de Estados
Americanos y la emisión de observación
electoral de la Unión Europea
denunciaron irregularidades en las
elecciones generales que hubo en
Guatemala el domingo pasado la oea pidió
que para la segunda vuelta presidencial
del 20 de agosto se disminuya la
atención y la polarización que hubo
durante estos comicios mientras que los
observadores de la Unión Europea
publicaron hoy su balance en el que
reiteraron que las votaciones estuvieron
marcadas por la exclusión de los
candidatos y el voto nulo y que la
elección se realizó en un deterioro del
Estado de derecho
[Aplausos]
y los dos candidatos que pasaron
álvarots en Guatemala son Sandra Torres
quien aspira por tercera vez a la
presidencia del país y Bernardo Arévalo
un candidato que dio la sorpresa en los
comicios Y es que aunque en las
encuestas no aparecía como uno de Los
favoritos fue el segundo aspirante más
votado Andrés triviño nos cuenta quienes
una firme Promesa de acabar con la
corrupción en Guatemala
Bernardo Arévalo dio una gran sorpresa
durante la primera vuelta de las
elecciones generales del 25 de junio su
nombre no figuraba entre los primeros en
las encuestas pero se ubicó en el
segundo puesto de las votaciones el
candidato de 64 años Fue diputado en los
últimos cuatro años y ha criticado la
represión en contra de jueces Fiscales y
periodistas exiliados bueno las más
urgentes van a ser todo lo relacionado a
la lucha contra la corrupción porque sin
lucha contra la corrupción no vamos a
poder rescatar las instituciones que
necesitamos para generar el desarrollo
su inesperado éxito electoral refleja
que una de las principales
preocupaciones de los guatemaltecos es
la corrupción que azota al país nació en
Uruguay y vivió varios años en Francia
durante el exilio de su padre el
expresidente Juan José Arévalo Bermejo
quien gobernó entre 1945 y 1951 y fue el
primer mandatario democrático de
Guatemala tras décadas dictatoriales
Bernardo Arévalo tiene estudios en
filosofía y antropología
diplomático desde la década de los 80s
en 2015 inició su activismo en contra
del gobierno lo que lo llevó a
convertirse en fundador y diputado del
movimiento semilla este 2023 obtuvo un
poco más del 12% en la primera ronda de
votaciones ahora enfrentará a la ex
primera dama y abanderada del
conservadurismo Sandra Torres que
consiguió el 16% No pues impresionadas
porque no
lo con señoras así verdad porque es bien
conocida Pero él ni nos imaginábamos de
que con él se iba a segunda vuelta
Arévalo ha prometido seguir los pasos de
su padre para mejorar la educación
reducir la violencia y la pobreza que
afecta al 59% de los 17.6 millones de
guatemaltecos también ha dicho que no
legalizará el aborto libre ni el
matrimonio igualitario pero aseguró que
no permitirá la discriminación ni
estigmatización por género ni religión
ahora con su eslogan de regresar la
democracia a Guatemala intentará llegar
a la casa presidencial
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos porque ABC
news publicaron grabaciones de audios en
las que supuestamente se prueba que el
expresidente Donald Trump no solo sabía
que tenía documentos clasificados en su
casa de marala Lago sino que además
revela detalles de seguridad nacional en
temas como irán a pesar de que esto se
puede sumar A las pruebas que tienen
contra y por las que los fiscales lo
acusan de 37 cargos penales Donald Trump
insiste en que todo se trata de una
cacería de brujas entonces
Esta es una continuación de la casa de
brujas más grande de todos los tiempos
Eso es todo y su objetivo principal es
la interferencia electoral y no vamos a
permitir que nos roben esta elección
Esta es una forma de manipular la
elección
[Aplausos]
porque manipularon las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020 y no vamos a
permitir que manipulen las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024
seguimos en Estados Unidos la
combinación de negligencia Mala conducta
y fallas absolutas en el desempeño
laboral del personal carcelario habría
permitido el suicidio de Jeffrey epstein
el multimillonario acusado de tráfico
sexual así lo determinó una
investigación del departamento de
Justicia estadounidense la pesquisa
indica que los empleados de la oficina
Federal de prisiones no registraron su
celda como se requiere ni lo controlaron
durante horas antes de que se suicidara
en 2019 además el informe advierte sobre
fallas en las cámaras de vigilancia y
que El Magnate tenía a su disposición
una cantidad excesiva de sábanas y ropa
que terminó utilizando para ahorcarse
es todo por el momento sigan en Franz 24
y en France 24.com
[Música]